oh I was going to upload something else
today but it got copyright strike thank
you thank you so much I'm so glad I came
back it's really moments like this that
makes me proud proud to make Beauty
videos because it's son okay
alright I need another video so instead
I'm gonna show you my favorite Twitter
account
I don't like Twitter don't get me wrong
here but this Twitter account I
discovered this when I was on a break
and it's so good it's called images that
precede unfortunate events they're funny
because they always take a moment they
always take a second I mean like what is
wrong with this image I get it it's a
curse image it's the one where some it
punishes the screen hilarious who we get
mad at a video game absolute betta
behavior SM edge very hard but why you
know I would never punch something if I
got mad no copy nah spoilers spoilers
come on if you haven't watched what is
it take it up on Gurren Lagann yet what
are you doing well I think funny this is
the classic video of the guy that shoves
a remote up his because he's so angry
that's a funny clip see when I saw these
10 years ago I was only 20 there's no
excuse of me not realizing that these
were fake it's so good
don't touch the remote don't grab that
remote ah guy freaks out the remote no
please not again miss Briggs that remote
my timers cuff what a classic what a
classic all right I don't see I don't
know see I don't know half of these I
swear to god that's a good one that's a
good one right there yeah what is this
oh that's funny
this is Homer before he gets hit by Bart
with Cher this is like a meme quick
trivia do I know the image this is a
dumb ways to die isn't it
another classic over Simpson mean where
he goes I close to Bart but there may be
a boogeyman or boogey man in the house
yes the ball pit the famous ball pit
this is from I don't know what it was
called but it was a tumbler con that's
right all the most insufferable people
on the internet decided to all just get
in the same room and this is what came
out of it Oh God is this when the birds
cry that anime where they rip out the
fingernails my god why do they make that
what he could actually notice something
right no these are funny let's come on
this is Silent Hill is this is when you
encounter the first enemy in Silent Hill
you know you know what I want one of
these for the bursar c'mon guy were the
horse scene you know what I mean when I
talk about torch scene or or right
before let me see if I can find that I
said this in my anime review of berserk
how that the manga just changes
completely there we go
here's an image before that proceed
unfortunate events oh I wouldn't pick
this scene but it still applies Kutner
is this parasite the final seed that's
fair that's definitely prayer I don't
know this one but I know a lot of people
will know this one I don't know what's
gonna happen maybe the key just explodes
or something really sad like maybe his
hair just disappears the classic if
you're an old school bro you know this
one corpse party that's right course
party well that had a nice conclusion
now if you watch anything that
historians ladies video it's really good
goddamn that soy face dude this is where
it all started
it's not proceeding unfortunate events
it's proceeding unfortunate culture in
men unfortunately oh my god Leroy
Jenkins that was a that was a Leroy
Jenkins reference in the latest
Supergirl episode and I really want to
make a video on it what is this I need
to know if you've seen this
you're also laughing right now okay
here's original 1/8 face
[Music]
stop now we're not doing that here sit
here I'm scared of clicking oh my god
scam it why would you do that why Oh
this world is rotten it's run why stared
no door he's kind of got that I didn't
to impose I like that I like that
hold x2 open door cuffs M&E oh man a
classic okay great some yeah don't do
that
idiot
[Music]
who did this and no
that's gotta be painful that's pain
that's pain right there how it keeps
going you can do anything and you did
this how does that feel
classic class no classic plastic aah
stop oh my god yes this one is amazing
and that was funny is I can't show it
because it's so awful but I can show
this and you can let your imagination
just flow Crystal Pepsi
swag swag is this the one where he
drinks like a 50 year old Crystal Pepsi
yeah that's it I don't know why you
would get the idea of doing that that
just seems like a bad idea and it sounds
it's a great title though isn't it but
like how is anything bad from this do
you want some yogurt that sounds great
what's wrong with the yogurt we will
never know I like this because the image
speaks for itself
half-life episode 2 yeah I bet you do we
all do yellow now I feel the same pain
all got a classic go knack girl I see
you tomorrow I would say this is
fortunate event because it's epic ha
some Hertz deeper some some of them this
is just like tough to get through but we
have to do we really really have to do
here it is there's birthday I thought
mine was better but oh my god and that's
where deaf no stop being fun I would to
watch yes I made a video on this old
school bras shouldn't so funny I wish
you'd just be quiet
who would have thought putting socially
inept people in the same room would
cause some sort of awkward scenario just
like what is this this keeps showing up
don't tell me he does something bad to
her I'm sure they just had a good time
oh Jesus Christ what's wrong with anime
master Nicky wait waited Jonah shut up
say I would kill if any child spoke to
me like that I would kill them too
I understand and the King's character
Artie
oh haha that's so sad a lot of these are
just screaming kids basically euthanasia
think about it ah another classic that
we all know and love
that define how do you this is like a
year ago how do you not play the game
already wait what is this images that
precede legendary events okay there's
another one I know which one I prefer
there it is yeah what did I get that oh
my god a classic oh is this before he
gets bitten oh this is one of my
favorite video game clips I'll show it
I've shown it before it's so good
I like this cuz I don't need to watch
your footage to understand that it's
gonna be funny
that's hilarious just that's so easy the
noobs man getting mad at video games
it's just like why oh my god this is not
going through my youtube history of
reaction of awful things I was wondering
the first to play that by the way yeah
that's right
I was a trendsetter yeah that's right I
was proud of it why was this in Super
Mario I hated that level
stupid singing piano no this is no
longer I take it back this is no longer
my favorite Twitter account this is
disgusting
at least I didn't get mad like one of
these oh my god can we show that clip
this is one of my first horror stuff I
ever do that was so scary
what is this yeah this is so funny
alright I'm gonna have to cut this one
here because I don't have a lot of time
since I have to reshoot because stinky
copyright but if you enjoyed this video
I really appreciated a thumbs up and
support the channel by subscribing 68%
of you aren't subscribed and I see you
guys tomorrow
Hado hey hey